this lecture consists of two parts that
deal with two rather different topics in
the first part we look into it an
important special case of a derived
distribution problem we start with two
independent random variables with known
distributions and wish to find the
distribution of their sum we will see
that for either the discrete or the
continuous case there is a nice formula
gives us the answer we will develop this
formula and then we will talk a little
bit about a graphical way of carrying
out the calculations involved as we will
discuss this formula also allows us to
establish the very important fact that
the sum of two independent normal random
variables is normal in the second part
who introduced the covariance of two
random variables and the correlation
coefficient these are certain quantities
that allow us to quantify the degree to
which two dependent random variables are
related for example a high value of the
correlation coefficient will indicate a
strong relation between these random
variables we will see the basic
mathematical properties of these
quantities and provide some
interpretation later on in this class we
will see that they play an important
role in the problem of estimating one
random variable given the value of
another